i want to start with uh how much i loved
your performance in this and and
how great this movie is uh it really hit
me emotionally
what was it like for you um i'm sure you
hadn't read the esquire article or maybe
you had but what was it like for you
first hearing about this story
and um what you know the emotional
reaction
i hadn't read this story um so that was
the first thing that i that i read
and it's it's a really well written
piece this is the article written by
mattie that the movie's based on
and um it's just really moving it's hard
it's hard not to be moved by it um
he's a great writer and so uh
you know sometimes man you you the first
thing you're drawn to in a movie is not
always the thing that you end up loving
the most about it uh
so at first i just thought like boy
that's a good story
i was really touched i wanted to talk to
the people involved and see what you
know gabriella thought about it she was
directing it um
and read the script that brad inglesby
wrote and um
he's written a lot of scripts so i sort
of had a i was
hoping for something really good and um
you know it's just not the kind of thing
that i ever really thought oh this is
what i want to do next you know you
never have that sense things just kind
of wash up on the shore and then
they have an impact on you and you say
like oh yeah i want to be part of that
movie
and i kind of felt like i want to be a
part of this movie i got it i wasn't
sure why it was so moving
um you know there's a tragedy at the
center of it uh
but it doesn't feel that um it doesn't
leave you with a sense of
um you know you're not just depressed at
the end of it it's not just
sad there's a lot a lot of emotions in
there one of the things i think the film
does very well
is it knows you have to mix in moments
of levity
in something with material like this you
can't just
pummel people with you know emotions um
and sort of i guess i want to make sure
that people realize there is levity in
this movie
and there are fun moments if you could
sort of mention that
yeah well jason siegel's really funny i
mean you put him in a movie and there
are going to be funny moments
and dakota is uh really fun and kind of
like a bright light and um she's gonna
be charming and you're gonna
it's gonna be hard to to uh dim that
light
um so that was really good casting by
gabriella
yeah i think dakota also had a lot of
the heavy lifting to do because she was
the person who had to be
playing someone who was dying and but
she also
by all accounts in real life her
character was you know real person
nicole and
that person as far as i anyone i talked
to
said that she was just the kind of
person that made everyone feel good
about being alive like one of those
people that just you like to be around
because they're fun
um and they're fun in a way that makes
everyone else have fun too
so she had to be that and also be
be playing the part of a mom who's who's
dying and is getting ready to say
goodbye to her kids
um so uh she had that responsibility of
making it sort of feel
almost like an uplifting movie and she
did a great job you've worked on a lot
of different genres a lot of different
projects
what is it like when you're playing the
very raw emotional scenes in the third
act
what was it like on set um were you guys
trying to keep levity on set were you
trying to maintain a certain emotional
thing you know what i mean yeah i mean
that doesn't always work for me i don't
like that sense of
oh here's a big day or everyone please
be quiet this is important hard work
i like to just come to work every day
sort of feeling the same and and do what
has to be done
and yeah i like it i don't know how many
movies i've made i've been
i've been really lucky i don't know 30
movies or something and
and so after a while you kind of get
used to it you know like you wait on
enough tables
you're kind of doing the same thing
every table comes up
you bring them take their order you go
to the kitchen you bring the food
um and sometimes there's a big order and
and you don't approach it any
differently you know you just stack
that a few extra plates on your arms and
you get it out there um
so those were some those are some hard
scenes you know just because uh
they are of their nature you know but
also there's cherry jones and there's
all these good actors around there just
doing stuff and i
you know just making it easy for
everyone by being good
so i kind of felt like i was in good
hands one of the things about this
project specifically is you filmed
in the real locations or you were in the
real place where
the story happened and you know you i'm
sure had people
family members possibly watching how did
that add to your
sort of how did that sort of affect you
on set did it affect you
knowing you had the the person you're
playing possibly right there
yeah well the person i was playing was
right there i mean matt teague who wrote
the article
and um he was the he was he was around
on set i talked to him you know going up
dinner with him
his kids were there um and his kids were
sort of the most important part
i just sort of thought like hey look
matt matt wrote this he created this
he wanted this to happen he's a grown-up
he understands
how movies can be different than real
life
um he he brought this on himself
and um but i for the kids i thought like
they probably didn't ask for this
you know and i i was i felt like it was
a great responsibility to make sure that
uh what i did whatever i could to
make the out the the final product be
something that was
did not um exacerbate or re-stimulate
the trauma of losing mom but in fact was
something that
um was another piece and sort of
the recovery and moving forward and and
and um
and you know there wasn't much i could
do but that was on my mind a lot
much more than like oh hey maybe this is
the neighbor who really
you knew these people um i felt like
that was
gabriela's uh territory the director she
has to worry about sort of like is this
movie something that
um is authentic enough that it uh
respects the real people and the real
story uh
you have been directing and i'm curious
how that
how directing has possibly changed the
way you are
on set have you noticed a different like
sort of way you conduct yourself or
anything because
you maybe have a better understanding of
what the director is going through
i might be more of a team player i mean
i might be you know
there was a time when i sort of felt
like what my job was
in some ways at odds with what the
director was doing i had to protect the
realism of the moment and a lot of
directors wanted that
for example i remember doing a scene in
this movie jesse james
and andrew dominic was a director and i
was sitting in a bathtub
and he's like you know i can't see you
from you know like
the angle that we're at this camera i
said well you're gonna
what do you wanna do stand up and take a
bath you gotta like you know
move the camera um he he and he was
really
uh he liked that approach you know is
that the actors have to sort of protect
the realism of what they would do
in this in a certain scene and he
worries about how to capture it
and then you know once i was a director
you know it could be a tough job and so
i was just you can't help but be more
empathetic after that
towards like okay we're running out of
time you know we're a team
we're all sort of doing this together
you really have to compromise sometimes
it's not always about
the actor sometimes it's about making
this
a shot that the camera team can actually
pull off
without having to take 30 minutes to
rebuild a room or something
um so i think i hope it's made me a
little bit more of a collaborator
in that way and um sometimes on the set
of this movie i saw gabrielle and i
thought
boy i'm glad i'm not the person who has
to solve this problem you know
really i could spend an hour talking
about jesse james but i gotta go
um listen congrats on this movie uh it's
so well done i wish you nothing but the
best
have a great day thanks steve appreciate
it man